hi guys so I'm here to invite you to
become a part of my super note team
you're probably like Justine I have no
idea what you're even talking about
right now well stay tuned because I'm
gonna tell you so the super note is
basically one single note that you hold
up for as long as you can now the
competition is very simple you join a
team I'm here to ask you should join my
team how did you join the team you make
a video response to this video quoting
out that note as long as you can the
team with the longest cumulative super
no turnover in the first wins so I'm
asking you to join the winning team and
that's my team so if you want to win
you're gonna join team iJustine join
make your video response and now I'm
gonna do my super note so here we go
okay you're ready
okay hopefully you can do a longer
supernote than me because if not our
team is going down actually no no no the
only team that's going down is every
other team because if you're not on Team
I just seen I just don't even know what
you mean leave your video response with
your super notes and I can't wait to be
the winning team okay all right let's
see your super notes see you guys soon